meanwhile it's almost summer break for
Clark County School District but just
because class will eventually be out
doesn't mean children should check out
CCSD has a summer acceleration program
it's five days a week for six hours none
of the program supports student learning
and really emotional well-being as well
it's being provided on all campuses for
free
we see this as a great investment again
to help our students recover from that
learning loss that may have that may
have been experienced with the distance
education and school closures
the summer acceleration program runs
from May 30th to June 16th we have
information on 8newsnow.com on how to
register your child